könnte es sein dass dieses Mal die
Ereignisse weit über ein einfaches
militärischer Scharmützel zwischen der
Terrorgruppe Hamas und dem Staat Israel
hinausgehen werden liegt diese Phase nun
hinter uns droht ein großer Krieg im
Nahen
Osten am 7 Oktober 2023 drangen hunderte
von Hamas Terroristen auf dem Land See
und Luftweg in Israel ein und zerstörten
alles was sich ihnen in den Weg stellte
die Operation alxafut hatte begonnen sie
ermordeten dabei über 1400 Menschen ohne
Rücksicht auf Alter
geschlechtntionalität oder Glauben
Männer Frauen und Kinder die spazieren
gingen picknickten in ihren Autos fuhren
auf einem friedensmusikfestival feierten
oder sogar in ihren eigenen Häusern oder
Luftschutzräumen Zuflucht gefunden
hatten wo immer sie vorbeikam
hinterließen die schlechte der chamas
eine tödliche Spur bestialischen
Ausmaßes ganz zu schweigen von den
Dutzenden von Menschen die entführt und
in den Gazastreifen gebracht wurden
die schrecklichen und harten Bilder des
hamasangriffs in Israel waren so düster
dass wir uns nicht einmal in der Lage
fühlen Sie hier wiederzugeben denn
natürlich würde YouTube das Video dann
sofort zensieren dabei wäre es enorm
wichtig gerade diese schrecklichen
grultaten allen zu zeigen auch wenn es
keine Darstellung gibt die die
wirklichen Qualen der Opfer
repräsentieren könnte ich bin mir sicher
dass die meisten von euch schon viele
dieser Bilder in anderen sozialen Medien
gesehen haben Bilder die eine Rohheit
widerspiegeln die wir bisher nur bei
Gruppen wie daes gesehen hatten eine
noch nie daagewesene Manifestation des
Hasses selbst nach den üblichen
Standards der Hamas israelisches
Musikfestival 260 Leichen von dem Ort
geborgen von dem Menschen im Kugelhagel
flohen chamas droht jedes Mal eine
zivile Geisel zu töten wenn Israel
Zivilisten im Gazastreifen ohne
Vorwarnung trifft dieses Mal hat die
Hamas eine Brutalität und
Unmenschlichkeit an den Tag gelegt die
wir selbst von einer solchen
Terrororganisation nicht gewohnt waren
sie hat damit die Maßstäbe grundlegend
und gültig verschoben sie ging diesmal
auch wesentlich koordinierter mit viel
mehr Männern und mit fortschrittlicheren
Mitteln und Methoden als sonst vor und
genau das eine Kombination aus
ungesehener Brutalität und ungesehener
Professionalität eine Menge Fragen
aufgeworfen wichtige
[Musik]
Fragen denn ist die chamas überhaupt von
sich aus in der Lage einen derartigen
Grad an terroristischer Professionalität
zu erreichen ohne dass ein operativer
Kopf dahinter steckt warum sollte sie
ausgerechtet zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
einen offenen und selbstmörderischen
Krieg gegen Israel beginnen wo sich doch
in letzter Zeit ihre Beziehungen zum
hebräerstaat stark verbessert hatten
über diesen Widerspruch der auch dazu
beigetragen hat dass die israelischen
Geheimdienste die Lage vollkommen falsch
eingeschätzt hatten berichteten wir euch
im letzten Video zum Thema ich werd es
euch verlinken natürlich sind wir noch
immer dabei die jüngsten Ereignisse
genau zu analysieren aber die Wahrheit
ist nun mal dass es immer mehr Anzeichen
gibt die auf ein bestimmtes Land
hinzuweisen scheinen wir sprechen
natürlich von der Islamischen Republik
Iran aber warum sollte der Iran
eigentlich hinter einer solchen grultat
stecken nun tatsache ist dass das
persische Land alle Gründe dazu hat eine
solche Aggression gegen Israel gerade
jetzt zu fördern meine Lieben Zuschauer
am Ende dieses Videos werdet ihr nicht
nur alle wichtigen Spuren die nach
dereran führen genau nachvollziehen
können sondern auch all jene
Zusammenhänge genau verstehen dabei
meist übersehen werden zuvor müssen wir
euch jedoch noch einen Tipp mit auf den
Weg geben wie ihr euer Wissen auch aus
ßhalb von visualpolitik boosten könnt
vielleicht fragt ihr euch ja manchmal
wie wir es schaffen so viel Wissen aus
verschiedenen Bereichen miteinander in
unseren Videos zu verknüpfen nun der
Schlüssel dazu ist vor allem lesen lesen
und manchmal auch hören Artikel Analysen
Videos Podcasts und vor allem Bücher mit
Grundlagenwissen das notwendig ist um
diese Information zu einem Gesamtbild
verknüpfen zu können aber was wenn man
gar nicht die Zeit dazu hat so viele
verschiedene Bücher zu lesen und genau
dann ist man bei blink ist richtig denn
es verschafft einem nicht nur mehr Zeit
sondern motiviert auch noch durch die
unterhaltsame Aufmachung denn die
Berliner Firma blinkist hat mit ihrem
Beitrag nicht nur das heutige Video
möglich gemacht nein wir nutzen Ihre App
auch selbst um täglich unseren eigenen
Wissenshorizont zu erweitern blinkist
bringt das Wichtigste aus mehr als 5000
Sachbüchern und Podcasts auf dein Handy
und dann erlebst du wirklich einen
ungeahnten wissensboost anstatt Stunden
in die Lektüre eines Buches zu stecken
und es dann vielleicht gar nicht zu Ende
zu lesen ziehst du dir in 0, nichts die
immer sehr angenehm und locker
geschriebene blinkest Version rein man
merkt gleich dass da echte Profis und
Talente am Werk sind stell dir vor wir
würden ein wertvolles aber langes Buch
in ein knackiges und leicht verdauliches
visualpolitik Video Gießen nun genau das
macht blinkist ein Beispiel sind Bücher
von Autoren mit denen man vielleicht
nicht immer einer Meinung ist womit aber
kann man seinen eigenen Horizont besser
erweitern als mit Information die eben
nicht aus der eigenen Babel stammen mir
ist z.B das Buch kein Kapitalismus ist
auch keine Lösung der ehemaligen TAS
Autorin Ulrike Herrmann aufgefallen auch
hier habe ich mir gesagt die Tatz ist ja
nicht gerade mein Leib und magenblatt
Rezensenten auf Amazon haben das Buch
auch dafür kritisiert langatmig zu sein
muss ich mir das also wirklich antun
andererseits hat mich schon interessiert
was da drin steht tja und dank der
festeln geschriebenen blinkistfassung
konnte ich innerhalb von nur 25 Minuten
herausfinden dass dieses Werk zumindest
in dieser blinkist Version mein Horizont
durchaus bereichern konnte solides
Wissen dass ich ohne blinkes sicher
verpasst hätte kurz gesagt diese App
wird mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit auch
dein Leben bereichern egal für welches
Thema du dich gerade interessierst die
Auswahl und das Spektrum sind wirklich
riesig von Finanzen über Wissenschaft
Politik Karriere bis zu klassischen
Ratgeberthemen wie man sein Leben
optimiert und so aber man kann mit
blinkist nicht nur sich selbst sondern
auch seine Lieben bereicher es hat
nämlich vor kurzem eine neue Funktion
namens blinkes spaces eingeführt damit
kannst du deine lieblingsblinks mit
deinen Freunden und Kollegen teilen und
mit ihnen darüber diskutieren wie in
einem Buchclub das coole daran ist dass
du blinkes basic User in deinen blinkes
space einladen kannst und diese können
dann alle Titel dort lesen oder hören
und zwar auch wenn diese normalerweise
nur für blink ist Premium User verfügbar
wären und das ist noch nicht alles
visualpolitik Zuschauer bekommen über
den Link in der Beschreibung nicht nur
zwei Mitgliedschaften zum Preis von
einer sondern oben drein noch 25% Rabatt
also zöger nicht besorg dir jetzt gleich
die kostenlose 7 Tage Testversion über
den Link unter diesem Video und fang
dann gleich damit an de Wissensschatz zu
bereichern übrigens falls Ihr uns ein
wenig bereichern möchtet in der
Videobeschreibung ist auch ein
Spendenlink mit dem ihr unsere Arbeit
auf freiwilliger Basis unterstützen
könnt und wenn ihr das erledigt habt
werden wir uns als nächsten Schritt zur
Ergründung der Iran connection lieber
mal die Hamas genauer ansehen je
Terrorgruppe die dieses historische
Massaker verübt hat
[Musik]
aufgepasst das schreckliche
Ziel um zu verstehen welche Rolle der
Iran in dieser ganzen Angelegenheit
gespielt haben könnte ist es äußerst
wichtig dass wir euch zunächst ein wenig
darüber erzählen was genau die Hamas
eigentlich darstellt welche Ansichten
dieser Organisation vertritt und vor
allem worauf sie
hinarbeitet die Kamas ist eine
Terrorgruppe mit einer jihadistischen
Ideologie die seit 2007 den Gazastreifen
regiert sie ist somit sowohl eine
Regierung als auch eine
Terrororganisation zur gleichen Zeit so
ähnlich wie das putinreime in Russland
und wie sind sie an die Macht gekommen
nun zi Jahre zuvor im Jahr 2005 zogen
sich die israelischen Streitkräfte die
die militärische Kontrolle über das
Gebiet hatten freiwillig zurück von
diesem Moment an brach im Gazastreifen
ein Machtkampf zwischen den beiden
Araber Fraktionen Hamas und fatach aus
dieser Machtkampf endete mit einer
gewaltsamen Übernahme der Macht in Gaza
durch die Hamas während die fatach die
Kontrolle über das Westjordanland
behielt ja es gab Wahlen aber im Grunde
hat die chamas später die ganze Macht
totalitär und mit Gewalt an sich
gerissen und warum ist das so wichtig
für das was wir euch in diesem Video
erklären wollen nun im Gegensatz zu dem
was viele Leute denken teilt oder
akzeptiert die chamas nicht die die
sogenannte zwei staatenlösung also der
Idee von zwei Staaten auf dem Gebiet des
historischen Israel einem jüdischen dem
neuen Israel und dem arabischen den die
Araber nach dem Vorbild der römischen
Kolonisatoren Palästina nennen die Römer
haben Israel bzw Judäa damals übrigens
einzig und allein zu dem Zweck nach den
Philistern in Palästina umbenannt weil
diese die damaligen Erzfeinde der Juden
waren die Umbenennung in Palästina
geschah also im Rahmen einer
psychopropagandistischen Aktion die alle
Bezüge des jüdischen Volkes zu zu ihrem
Land brechen sollte nun dieser Plan ist
leider aufgegangen und leider hat sich
auch der Begriff Palästina bis heute
gehalten und viele Menschen wissen
einfach nicht dass es sich eigentlich um
einen beleidigenden imperialistisch
kolonialistischen Kampfbegriff handelt
der den Anspruch der Juden auf ihre
Stammlande delegitimieren soll aber mal
ganz abgesehen von den Begrifflichkeiten
gibt es auf der anderen Seite eben die
fatach die eine Zweistaatenlösung mehr
oder weniger akzeptieren würde im
Gegensatz zur chamas
um es klar zu sagen im Fall der Hamas
verfolgt diese Organisation die
vollständige Auslöschung des Staates
Israel und die Ermordung und Vertreibung
der Juden aus der Region durch den Jihad
sie sind der Meinung dass dieses gesamte
Gebiet den Muslimen gehört und dass das
einzige Gesetz das dort gelten sollte
die Sharia ist ihr glaubt mir nicht dann
schaut euch doch z.B diese beiden
Artikel aus der gründungskarter der
Hamas an sie könnten es nicht deutlicher
machen die Grundstruktur der Hamas
besteht aus Muslimen die Allah den sie
wahrhaftig anbeten die Treue geschworen
haben die ihre Pflicht gegenüber sich
selbst ihren Familien und ihrem Land
kennen dabei fürchten sie Allah und
erheben das wandner des Jihad gegen die
Unterdrücker damit sie das Land und die
Menschen von ihrer Unreinheit ihrer
Niedertracht und ihren Übeln befreien
Artikel 3 des hamaspakts von
1988 die Hamas glaubt dass das Land
Palästina ein islamischer wachf das
heißt eine heilige unveräußerliche
Schenkung ist der für zukünftige Muslim
ische Generation bis zum Tag des
Jüngsten Gerichts geweiht ist es oder
ein Teil davon darf nicht aufgegeben
werden dies ist das Gesetz das in der
islamischen Sharia für das Land
Palästina gilt und dasselbe gilt für
jedes Land das die Muslime mit Gewalt
erobert haben Artikel 11 des hamaspakts
von 1988 mit anderen Worten wie ihr seht
ist die Hamas keineswegs so etwas wie
eine palästinensische Befreiungsbewegung
wie sie auch viele irregeleitete im
Westen nennen nein sie ist im Grunde
nichts anderes als eine dihadistische
Gruppe die einzig und allein das Ziel
verfolgt die territoriale Kontrolle des
Islams zu expandieren und genau darauf
arbeitet sie schon seit Jahren
hin es handelt sich also im Wesentlichen
um eine weitere terroristische Gruppe im
Stile anderer Gruppierungen wie z.B
daesch dem sogenannten islamischen Staat
dem islamischen dihad oder al-qida dabei
spielt es keinerlei Rolle dass die Hamas
auch einen politischen Arm hat denn
letztlich dient auch die dieser der
Erreichung derselben Ziele nur eben auf
noch heuchlerischere Weise als beim
militärischen sie sind aber ganz klar
zwei Arme an einem terroristischen
Körper in dessen Kopf der Völkermord
fest verankert ist und das ist etwas was
ich wirklich betonen möchte denn dieser
Punkt ist entscheidend sie unterstützen
weder die zwei staatenlösung noch
glauben sie an sie noch akzeptieren Sie
sie der Gazastreifen an sich ist ein
sehr gutes Beispiel dafür die Hamas
regiert ihn seit 2007 mit eiserner Faust
und ihr Hauptziel dort ist es den Kampf
mit Israel aufrecht zu erhalten von den
jahrelangen andauernden
raketenbombardements bis zur brutalen
Aggression vom 7 Oktober denn wenn die
Hamas in ihrer gründungskarte vom dihad
spricht meint sie damit im Wesentlichen
die Vernichtung Israels und dazu gehören
zwei Dinge einerseits unterscheidet sich
die Hamas als selbsterklärte
jihadistische Terrorgruppe von der
fatachreierung im Westjordanland die die
zwei staatenlösung akzeptiert natürlich
scheint angesichts der jüngsten
Ereignisse diese Lösung jedoch nur noch
eine fat Morgana zu sein sein das heißt
wenn wir über Araber auf dem Gebiet des
historischen Israel reden müssen wir
ganz klar zwischen den arabischen
Staatsbürgern Israels zwischen dem
fatachreime im Westjordanland und dem
hamasreime in Gaza unterscheiden sie
sind absolut nicht dasselbe zwar ist
auch die fatach kein engelsor aber sie
ist nun mal das kleinere Übel
andererseits ist das Thema jihat auch
deshalb so wichtig weil die Hamas das
gleiche Ziel verfolgt wie Israels
historische Feinde nämlich die
Vernichtung des Hebräischen Landes und
da sie den Gaza Streifen beherrscht und
kontrolliert ist die Hamas natürlich ein
enorm wichtiger fast unverzichtbarer
Akteur in jeder Konfrontation mit
Israel aufgrund der geographischen Lage
des gasastreifens und der totalen
Kontrolle über dieses Gebiet ist es für
die chamas ein leichtes Israel zu
destabilisieren und anzugreifen das tun
sie wie gesagt schon seit Jahren mit
Raketen und genau das haben sie auch am
7 Oktober getan und genau diese
Fähigkeit hat die sunitische Hamas für
Israels großen Gegner sehr attraktiv
gemacht die Rede ist natürlich vom
schiitischen Iran seit der islamischen
Revolution von 1979 verfolgte Iran eine
Politik der Feindschaft und der aktiven
Konfrontation gegenüber dem Hebräischen
Staat es wird ständig mit Krieg und
Zerstörung gedroht aber was genau will
der persischsiitische Iran eigentlich in
der arabisch-sunitischen Region welche
Beweggründe hat die Islamische Republik
um sich so aktiv gegen Israel zu stellen
schließlich war Persien unter dem Schal
noch eine der engsten Verbündeten
Israels und vielleicht die wichtigste
Frage von allen warum scheint Teran
gerade jetzt beschlossen zu haben mit
absolut harten Bandagen zu kämpfen und
diesen brutalen Vorstoß gegen sein
ernstfeind zu unterstützen oder gar
aktiv zu fördern nun genau das werden
wir uns jetzt ansehen hört gut
zu die Faust im
Schatten wie wir euch bereits in
früheren Videos auf visualpolitik
berichtet haben haben den letzten Jahren
einige der einflussreichsten Länder der
arabischen Welt ihre Haltung gegenüber
Israel allmählich geändert den Höhepunkt
dieses Prozesses stellt bisher das
abrahamabkommen da mit dem zunächst die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate und dann
bachrein den Staat Israel anerkannten
und normale diplomatische Beziehung zu
ihm Aufnahmen später schlossen sich
ihnen der Sudan und Marokko an fakt ist
dass die USA seit der Unterzeichnung der
ersten Abkommen im Jahr 2020 an der
Seite Israels daran arbeiten den
Geltungsbereich zu erweitern Roman
Jordanien Kuweit und vor allem
Saudi-Arabien tatsächlich waren die
Verhandlungen mit dem letzt genannten
Land kurz vor den Anschlägen schon weit
fortgeschritten das Abkommen zwischen
Riad Jerusalem und Washington sollte das
Sahnehäubchen sein auf diesem ganzen
friedenskuchen der große politische
Meilenstein der den Nahen Osten für
immer verändern und sicherer machen
würde und bedenkt bitte dass neben der
Anerkennung Israels alles darauf
hindeutet dass dieses Abkommen auch mit
der Erneuerung der US
Sicherheitsgarantie für Saudi-Arabien
und vielleicht sogar mit der saudischen
Ankündigung seine Ölproduktion zu
erhöhen einhergehen würde Riad erklärt
sich bereit die Ölproduktion zu erhöhen
um eine Normalisierung der Beziehungen
zu Israel zu erreichen Saudi-Arabien
bietet eine Produktionssteigerung als
Geste für ein historisches
dreiwegeabkommen an das auch einen
amerikanisch-sudischen verteidigungspakt
den Erwerb von Rüstungsgütern und ein
ziviles Atomprogramm umfassen würde
berichtet das wallstet Journal tja am 7
Oktober wurde das allerdings alles zu
Nichte gemacht im Grunde handelt es sich
um einen Dominoeffekt bei dem man seh
den Auges auf den Abgrund zusteuert ohne
irgendetwas dagegen unternehmen zu
können der beispiellose Angriff der
Hamas zieht ganz unweigerlich ebenfalls
beispiellose israelische vergeltungs und
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen nachs sich diese
wiederum eröffnen den Israel Hassern und
Saboteuren des Friedensprozesses eine
riesige Palette an
propagandagelegenheiten um sowohl die
westliche als auch vor allem die
islamische Öffentlichkeit aufzuhetzen
und die arabische bzw gesamtislam is
Straße setzte dann fein orchestriert
durch ultraareligiöse Strippenzieher und
machtspieler die jeweiligen Herrscher
unter Druck ihr Handlungsspielraum bei
der Normalisierung der Verhältnisse zu
Israel wird dadurch automatisch
eingeschränkt das perfide dabei ist dass
die muslimische Straße genauso wie viele
Juden und Israel Hasser überhaupt keine
Fakten braucht um Israel zu verurteilen
ein weiteres trauriges Beispiel in einer
schier endlosen Reihe letztlich
erfolgreicher verläumdungsversuche war
in diesen Tagen wieder der Absturz einer
vom islamischen Jihad abgefeuerten
Rakete auf den Parkplatz eines
Krankenhauses in Gaza die Hamas
schlachtete diesen selbstverschuldeten
Unfall sofort propangadistisch aus indem
sie behauptete es seien die Israelis
gewesen die das Krankenhaus bombardiert
hätten und die Zahl der Todesopfer liege
über 500 das alles waren natürlich
gezielte Desinformationen die schon nach
kurzer Zeit anhand einer ganzen Reihe
von Beweisen widerlegt werden konnten
das wirklich tragische war dann aber
dass viele große Medien im Westen von
der New York Times bis zu ARD Tagesschau
diese wirklich gefährlich Desinformation
der Hamas die sich hinter dem Hamas
geführten Gaza Gesundheitsministerium
versteckte unreflektiert und ungeprüft
übernahmen und als Tatsache in die Welt
hinausposaunen über die Motive dieser
hetzmultiplikatoren habe ich auf meinem
persönlichen Kanal einen Livestream
aufgenommen und ich werde ihn euch
verlinken fakt ist nun mal auch wenn
solche Fake News aufliegen bleibt der
erste Eindruck bei vielen Leuten die
eben der Washington Post der New York
Times dem Guardian oder der Tagesschau
Vertrauen hängen nur Er ist es Der für
sie zählt und in der muslimischen Welt
ist es noch viel schlimmer dort glauben
viele Leute auch dann noch an die Lüge
selbst wenn sie mit ihren eigenen Augen
den Gegenbeweis sehen denn dabei geht es
nicht darum ob etwas Wahrheit oder Lüge
ist sondern ob es gegen die Juden geht
die Psyche dieser Menschen könnte es
nicht zulassen sich die Lüge
einzugestehen weil dann ihr komplettes
seit ihrer Kindheit verinnerlichtes Bild
von den bösen Juden die für ihr Unglück
verantwortlich sind und vom Bösen Westen
der sie nur unterdrückt in sich
zusammenbrechen würde daher ist es viel
leichter sich KLE in dieser Selbstlüge
der täteropferumkehr zu bestärken ein
Phänomen das z.B auch bei vielen Putin
Fans und Anhängern der russischen Welt
zu finden ist allerdings stellen
letztere quantitativ und demographisch
eher einen kleinen vorübergehenden
Platscher da gegenüber dem
radikalislamischen Tsunami der immer
weiter anwächst und auch immer mehr
westliche Länder mit muslimischer
Minderheit überrollt es handelt sich um
ein Tsunami vor dem auch immer mehr
Politiker einknicken einmal sind es die
von Berliner Senat kontrollierten
Verkehrsbetriebe die die Plakatwerbung
mit den Fotos der nach Gaza entführten
Israelis verbieten da sie die Gewalt der
Berliner hamasanhänger fürchten und ein
andermal könnten es eben die Saudis sein
die kurz vor dem Ziel Angst vor dem vom
Hass aufgepeitschten Menschenmassen in
ihrem eigenen Land bekommen tja und
geostrategisch stellt sich natürlich vor
allem die Frage wem dieser Deal die
Erweiterung des Abraham Abkommens um
Saudi-Arabien die kurz vor der
Bekanntgabe zu stehen schien am meisten
Schaden
würde nun ja vielleicht sahen sich auch
die Hamas und selbst die vertacht durch
ihn ins Abseits geschoben klar sie
hätten eine Menge Einfluss verloren und
vor allem das Ziel der Hamas Israel
auszulöschen wäre damit in noch weitere
Ferne gerückt andererseits muss man
jedoch auch sehen dass sie von der in
letzter Zeit stattfindenden
lockerungspolitik der Israelis
wirtschaftlich stark profitiert haben
wir haben darüber erst kürzlich ein
Video auf visualconomic gedreht dass ich
euch verlinken werde okay und natürlich
darf man nie vergessen dass die Führer
der Arber in Gaza und der Westbank schon
alle möglichen für Sie positiven
Kompromisslösungen aus geschlagen haben
da diese ihre Maximalforderungen nicht
erfüllten aber würden sie deswegen
gleich ein noch nie da gewesenes Inferno
herauf beschwören dass auch noch ihr
eigenes Todesurteil bedeuten könnte tja
es wird also recht schnell klar dass sie
nicht die hauptprofeteure ihres eigenen
Handelns sein können nein denn es gibt
vor allem eine Regionalmacht einen
Giganten unter den Giganten in der
muslimischen Welt für den das Abkommen
zwischen Saudi-Arabien und Israel
absolut fatal gewesen wäre und daher um
jeden Preis verhindert werden musste ihr
wisst ganz genau von wem ich
spreche der Iran war ist und wird
solange die Islamische Republik besteht
der historische und entschiedene Feind
Israels sein die Auslöschung Israels
gehört auch zu den gründungsstatuten des
Mull Regimes und für die ayatollas ist
das abrahamabkommen ein historischer
Verrat am Islam durch die arabischen
Unterzeichnerstaaten und genau aus
diesem Grund sind Tehran die
Revolutionsgarden und die alkutzttruppe
in den letzten Jahren zum wichtigsten
Einflussfaktor der anti-Israel beewegung
auf internationaleer Ebene geworden eben
auch für die bei den Schiiten so
verhasen sunnitischen Gruppierungen und
abgesehen von der religiösen Frage hätte
die Anerkennung Israels durch
Saudi-Arabien den Interessen des Iran
einen schweren strategischen Schlag
versetzt sein Einfluss in der Region
würde schwinden seine Öleinnahmen würden
sinken und die neue Allianz aus den USA
Israel Saudi-Arabien und den anderen
arabischen Ländern hätte es leichter
jede Operation zu Zerschlagung des
iranischen Atomprogramms durchzuführen
für die mullas wäre dies ein
geostrategischer Gau gewesen erschwerend
kommt hinzu dass die anti-israelkampagne
des Irans dazu geführt hat dass der von
den ayatollas kontrollierte schiitische
Zweig des Islams unter den radikaleren
Suniten die mit ihren jeweiligen
Regierungen unzufrieden sind an
Attraktivität gewinnt tatsächlich
finanziert trainiert und bewaffnet der
Iran seit Jahrzehnten alle möglichen
arabischen Terrorgruppen um das Land der
Hebräer zu bekämpfen und anzugreifen
natürlich sprechen wir hier speziell
über die drei wichtigsten operativen
Zweige des Irans in der Region die
chamas in Gaza die hesbala im Libanon
und das Assad Regime in Syrien dazu
gehören noch einige vom Iran
unterstützte Milizen im Irak die großen
Einfluss auf die irakische Regierung
haben wie ihr seht handelt es sich also
nicht um Peanuts wir sprechen von einer
Konfrontation die direkt oder indirekt
sogar dazu geführt hat dass sowohl
Israel als auch der Iran militärisch in
das Land des jeweils anderen
eingegriffen
haben ganz genau im Jahr 2018 feuert
iranische Streitkräfte Raketen auf
israelische Stellungen auf den
Golanhöhen und wie wir bereits erwähnt
haben ist Teheran für die Finanzierung
Bewaffnung und Ausbildung von
gruppenverantwortlich die Israel immer
wieder angreifen das hebäische Land hat
seinerseits auch zahlreiche Operationen
im Land ayatollas durchgeführt so steckt
Israel beispielsweise hinter der
Ermordung von mindestens fünf
Wissenschaftlern des iranischen
Atomprogramms seit 2010 ebenso macht die
iranische Regierung Israel für eine
gewaltige Explosion in ihrer größten
Urananreicherungsanlage im april 2021
verantwortlich im Oktober 2021
Beschuldigte ein iranischer general
Israel einen cyberangrff durchgeführt zu
haben der Tankstellen im ganzen Land LM
legte und im Januar 2022 wurde ein
Munitionsdepot in der Nähe der Stadt
isban mit einer Drohne angegriffen wofür
ebenfalls Israel verantwortlich gemacht
wurde wie ihr seht haben wir es mit
einem echten Kalten Krieg im Nahen Osten
zu tun und der Iran hat so eben die
heiße Phase eingeleitet denn wenn ihr
mal darüber nachdenkt er gibt ein derart
braachiales vorgehende der Hamas gegen
Israel nur in diesem Licht einen
sin einerseits könnte es das
israelischsudische Abkommen entgleisen
lassen und so den Gau für den Iran noch
mal kurz vor knapp abwenden und dabei
geht es nicht nur um die Ölpreise
andererseits stärkt es die Position der
herans als große politisch religiöse
Referenz in der muslimischen Welt die
einzigen die ihren Versprechen treu
bleiben ganz Israel zu islamisieren seht
euch mal diesen Tweet des iranischen
Ayatollah hamenei an der nur vier Tage
vor dem brutalen Hamas Angriff
veröffentlicht wurde Tweet vom 3 Oktober
2023 das usurpationsregime geht seinem
Ende entgegen die palästinensische
Jugend und die antiunterdrückungs und
antibesatzungsbewegung in Palästina sind
heute energischer lebendiger und besser
vorbereitet als je zuvor in den letzten
70 oder 80 Jahren so Gott will wird die
Bewegung ihrer Ziele erreichen Ayatollah
Ali hamenei tja und nur vier Tage später
startete die Hamas ihren schrecklichen
Angriff ich meine kann das ein Zufall
sein urteilt selbst und passt auf denn
neben dem Iran gibt es noch einen
weiteren wichtigen Akteur der ebenfalls
stark vom Hamas Angriff profitiert hat
na habt ihr schon eine Vorahnung von dem
wir sprechen nun schaut's euch
an neben der Islamischen Republik Iran
könnte auch Putins Russland direkt von
der Hamas Operation profitieren
schließlich stellte das dreiseitige
Abkommen zwischen den USA Saudi-Arabien
und Israel auch einen der wichtigsten
Schlüssel der Politik des Weißen Hauses
gegen Putin da überlegt mal mit dies
Abkommen hätten die USA die weltweite
Ölknappheit abmildern können das hätte
natürlich dazu geführt dass die
Rohölpreise und damit die Öleinnahmen
Russland sinken und gleichzeitig hätte
es die wirtschaftliche Lage der
westlichen Volkswirtschaften verbessert
etwas was Putin um jeden Preis
verhindern möchte denn diese
wirtschaftliche Erleichterung im Westen
hätte die Erosion der öffentlichen
Unterstützung für den ukrainekrieg die
gerade stattfindet und über die wir im
letzten Video berichtet haben begrenzt
tja das alles hängt ganz eng miteinander
zusammen und alle Spieler in Moskau
Teheran Riad und Washington wissen dies
es ganz genau und wenn wir bedenken dass
Moskau und ter an sich in den letzten
Jahren ziemlich nah gekommen sind
scheint das alles nicht mehr so zufällig
zu sein oder okay aber was waren nun die
genauen Anzeichen für all diese
Verwicklungen über die wir hier sprechen
auf welche Weise genau wurde der blutige
Angriff der Hamas am 7 Oktober
inszeniert nun das werden wir jetzt ganz
genau unter die Lupe nehmen
aufgepasst ein vereinbarter Krieg
selten hat die Planung eines Krieges
einer Invasion einer Militäraktion oder
eines Terroranschlags so viele Anzeichen
Spuren und Hinweise hinterlassen bevor
sie stattfanden und selten hat der
israelische Militärgeheimdienst in dem
Fall Aman und Schabak mit seinen
Vorhersagen dermaßen daneben gelegen nur
damit kein falscher Eindruck entsteht
auch in der Vergangenheit haben sich die
für unfehlbar gehaltenen geheimdien
Israelis zu einige peinliche Schnitz
gleich ist aber diesmal war es noch mal
eine Nummer krasser seit August gab es
mehr als deutliche Beweise für
Vorbereitungen und Truppenbewegungen
zwischen der Hamas der hisballah und dem
iranischen Regime wir sprechen z.B von
Treffen an verschiedenen Orten deren
Regelmäßigkeit und Häufigkeit höchst
ungewöhnlich
waren so haben laut Berichten des Wall
Street Journal hochrangige Mitglieder
der Hamas und der hesball zugegeben dass
iranische Amtsträger bei der Planung des
Hamas Überraschungsangriffs geholfen und
ihnen bei einem Treffen in Beirut am
Montag den 2 Oktober 2023 grünes Licht
gegeben haben die Einzelheiten des
hamasangriffs der größten Verletzung der
israelischen Grenzen seit dem
jumkipurkrieg 1973 wurden Berichten
zufolge bei mehreren Treffen in Teheran
der Türkei und Beirut mit Vertreter der
Hamas des Irans und der hballah
ausgehandelt demselben Bericht zufolge
sollen funktionäer der islamischen
Revolutionsgarde des Irans an der
Planung von Luft Land und seeangriffen
gearbeitet haben die die kramas
durchführen
könnte
ihr seht also dass nach allem was wir
heute gesehen haben die Beteiligung des
Irans an diesem Konflikt praktisch eine
Tatsache ist auch wenn sie von den am
meisten beteiligten Regierungen noch
nicht bestätigt wurde der Iran hatte
mehr als genug Motive um zu handeln und
einen Angriff genau zu dem Zeitpunkt zu
unterstützen zu dem er dann tatsächlich
stattfand bei der quibono Frage steht
der unangefochten und meilenweit an der
Spitze alle Verschwörungstheorien wonach
der Anschlag z.B von Netanyahu oder den
Israel Geheimdiensten selbst inszeniert
oder provoziert worden wäre verschwinden
hinter dem iranischen motivgebirge als
klitze kleine Huppel und bei nrem
Hinsehen wie gesagt eben eher als Dellen
es scheint klar zu sein dass dieser
jüngste Krieg über den Konflikt zwischen
Israel und Gaza hinausgehen wird er wird
höchstwahrscheinlich große regionale und
sogar globale Auswirkungen haben hier
auf visualpolitik werden wir alles was
passiert genau im Auge behalten und euch
wie immer umfassend über die
Zusammenhänge informieren weitere
interessante Videos über dieses Thema
und auch die Iran connection findet ihr
auch auf meinem persönlichen Kanal den
ich euch hinter dem i oben rechts
verlinke der Link ist dann auch unter
diesem Video zu finden also schaut dort
ruhig mal vorbei und dann würde mich
natürlich auch noch eure Meinung
interessieren glaubt ihr dass der Iran
direkt in den Angriff der Hamas auf
Israel verwickelt ist wie hoch schätzt
ihr die Chancen auf einen Krieg zwischen
Israel und dem Iran ein oder sogar auf
einen größeren Konflikt an dem die USA
selbst beteiligt werden wie immer sind
wir auf eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleichtwas dabei gelernt habt falls
ja gibt uns bitte ein Like und halilt es
mit euren Freunden natürlich V wir auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
un dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den
Link dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis
bald